[Music]
and art versus life news submitted by
milk before cereal you [ __ ] little
piece of [ __ ] over that create a lot of
like floaties I did that once and I was
a kid and I was like never again this
guy's an amateur Kareem abdul-jabbar
slams Quentin Tarantino for his
portrayal of Bruce Lee in his recent
movie oh you really don't get out seen
it I watched it and I hated the whole
time going what the [ __ ] is happening
wait why did they introduce that
character wait what are we doing now I'm
a fan of Tarantino I'm a big fan I was
some trash Ashton did you know that he
has a giant dildo that he brings to
every set for shits and giggles and
they'd leave it there for funsies that's
the only good thing I heard during this
press tour kid Oh weird Wow I heard that
married recently Terry
was it an Asian lady no what is the
invasion yeah he's supposed to have a
Zinna feet I think
feets I heard about that yeah oh those
feet in this was a lot yeah is it only
female feets oh yeah there's a there's a
there's a big feet scene that takes a
long yeah Margot Robbie was
pseudopatients up like half of the
[ __ ] screen it's like it's like right
here the hole yeah I'm like the whole
scene it's just yeah and even I noticed
that but I did like the ass one until I
found out she was underage when she's
talking through the car she's just
[ __ ] look yeah I was like how dare
you you I know why you did that you
[ __ ] horny bastard she's the actress
is underage of the characters under Oh
I was in a fun video for a second
you [ __ ] up see I thought so I think
you all right now I was like yes no joke
is to apologize for something this would
be sick so Kareem abdul-jabbar's is what
he currently looks like hey this gonna
be a dumb question
basketball player he also worked with
Bruce Lee yeah he was also an airplane
so he's an actor also he had a couple
things I mean he was basically himself
in this looks oh [ __ ] mask yeah actor
playing rich wow that's really good
portraying Bruce Lee yeah he's great
yeah and here's when they were together
yeah what's that game a death or
something right yeah yeah yeah I think
Kareem was like the last level so in
that movie Bruce Lee goes up every
single level and then there's like a
different fighter for each one that well
you wouldn't think Krisha who's who's
the last guy who's the last boss kareem
abdul-jabbar famous basketball right
like it's so funny I love Hollywood
sometimes yeah so he wrote this piece on
The Hollywood Reporter website and so he
was saying like human titled like the
headline of it says Kareem abdul-jabbar
Bruce Lee was my friend and Tarantino's
movie disrespects him so as you guys
have seen the movie he portrayed as this
is a [ __ ] yeah super arrogant guy that
pretty much wants to pick a fight with a
Brad Pitt's character who Bret I mean
Kareem is saying like you know this guy
cliff Brad Pitt's character he's already
like past his prime and he like Bruce
Lee and ends up getting thrown onto a
car and it seems as though Bruce Lee
lost this squabble that they had yeah
specious squabble it's not real talking
no it's a real thing it didn't happen
buuut didn't exist so yeah mad that they
made Bruce Lee lose a fight no they're
mad they're mad of the portrayal of
Bruce Lee he's like a carrot but the
character I realize why they did it that
way because it's an imagination of cliff
yes but but all the whole
also it just sucks it just it just sucks
the way that it that they portrayed him
do you mean by imagine he was
daydreaming yeah remember he's in the
hues he was thinking back he was on the
roof working on his antenna and he's
thinking back and then in that seat is
his memory of how things went down it's
a memory or is it a fantasy or is it an
actual danger that's where its
interpretive you know you don't know but
that's that's literally him thinking
back so it could have been what happened
or could have been what cliff imagine
and of course cliff thinks he's the
[ __ ] boss right yeah but the problem
here is I think it plays into the whole
idea of what loosely was trying to fight
against is the stereotypes and what
Tarantino did is he ended up portraying
Bruce Lee in this light of what he was
fighting against and and in accurately
portraying him saying like he could [ __ ]
up
Muhammad Ali Cassius Clay all that stuff
and I actually never said he actually
said the habla to the other yeah yeah
but who gives a [ __ ] it's a movie that
that's the thing like like this movie
portrays the Sharon Tate murders as like
a big bit like they use Manson and his
followers as a bit too but like the yeah
and cliff ends up [ __ ] killing those
followers yeah I mean yeah then and in a
silly way like he kills him the silliest
way he literally barbecue is one of them
in a pool
yeah like it's not like this movies like
here to portray accurate Hollywood or
any of that [ __ ] it's completely hyper
[ __ ] fantasized so okay so that is
what Tarantino's saying as well but at
the same time he's saying because he
commented on this whole thing he was
like Bruce Lee was an arrogant guy so
he's still standing by the way he's
portraying him but then in the very same
conversation he's saying but is is all
fictional so he's contradicting himself
you can't really compare his argument
with creams cuz Kareem knew him yeah and
he learned from him inept direct access
Quentin Tarantino saying he's an
arrogant guys he studied him or he heard
about him so I think if he just stuck to
his guns and was like oh yeah this is
just a fictional version of Bruce Lee I
think his argument would be stronger
exactly that's what I was trying to get
to so then they're also saying oh so
Korean was saying that
you know the sure you can portray him
however you want and that's what you did
and it is a fictional world but not when
it's gonna be detrimental towards it
like the public image especially with
people of today seeing Bruce Lee and
that's the image that they have of Bruce
Lee of but that's how he was in real
life it's almost I think from Koreans
perspective like Bruce Lee he was like
the Martin Luther King for Asians so
everything that he was fighting for to
bring Asians have equal representation
and then now you just kind of like
cartoon eyes Martin Luther King and he's
getting his ass beat and it's just it's
for some people Bruce Lee is really
sacred and if you know Bruce Lee his
philosophy is you want to train as much
as you can so you never have to fight
yeah he's the type of person that would
never challenge anybody but everyone
always challenged him and he's always
the type that of those I if you want a
child I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out that's
because of his portrayal in the movies
like you know I'm saying like in movies
he was a cocky [ __ ] in movies
ass you play the character right so when
you're watching that though that's what
people made used to make fun of in the
in the seventies eighties even even the
90s like in The Naked Gun movies and
[ __ ] they were making fun of this Bruce
Lee that's like even though Jim Carrey
seen in Dumb and Dumber he's like like
all that shit's just a it's just taking
Bruce Lee from the movie parroting that
that's all people know people don't
[ __ ] watch all the interviews and
they're watching him on [ __ ] 60
minutes and [ __ ] like people don't care
about that people who view the culture
they go oh yeah Bruce Lee was a cocky
[ __ ] it's not that it was
accurate but I buddy like when you hear
his daughter saying like he wasn't like
this it's like no like of course not but
that's how he was in Polynesia movies
right and I also think it's it's a
touchy subject because you're dealing
with not only one a group of people that
see him like as like Asian Americans see
him as like a legend right and you're
destroying that but there's also the
whole martial arts community that view
and in the way he died was way like it
was kind of weird and tragic and and
it's really fast so so it's better see
to like who knows we yeah so when you
deal with legends like this is real
death like when you died in sleepers
there's just some enough oh you got shot
on the trucks
son no he had like a brain all right and
I need and then Bruce Lee died in his
because he didn't uh he was on set and
then they had to take him to the
hospital because he was suffering some
like stroke or something and he had some
brain issue or whatever blaming it on
him being allergic to aspirin it could
be and it's not clear just awesome
people I think someone poisoned them
yeah like this poison is wheats - oh
there's just like so many I already died
cuz this guy threw him into a car with a
legend and you're dealing with touchy
subjects like that I think you have to
do you have to do it justice cuz you're
gonna piss a lot of [ __ ] people off
but that's what's crazy right like you
could you should be able to take a
celebrity make him do your movie
whatever like there should be like a
revered like all this celebrity you
can't touch this one you know I'm saying
like like that's like doing a Martin
Luther King biopic and talking about not
talking about how he cheated on his wife
and like of course but you got to be
ready for getting people mad is what I'm
saying you can't what I was reading as
well as like he didn't even balance it
from like the real life Bruce Lee how he
really is and like it was just nothing
but this fake portrayal like this
fictitious way of how he acted but
honestly I think what Tarantino really
made this worse is by his quote so I'll
just read it directly he said Bruce Lee
was kind of an arrogant guy the way he
was talking I didn't just make a lot of
that up I heard him say things like that
to that effect if people are saying
quote well we well he never said he
could beat up Muhammad Ali well yeah he
did not only did he say that but his
wife Linda Lee said that in her first
biography I ever read she absolutely
said that yes she said it he didn't say
yeah yeah yeah he thought Muhammad Ali
would kick his ass yeah for even though
they're saying he's misquoting a lot of
[ __ ] that what she said wasn't even that
either she was quoting someone else that
said that so it wasn't even accurate it
yeah yeah so he had him in the movie for
three minutes he's not gonna like and
then like he goes home and he sits down
after a long day on set and like he
weeps because like all he's not
understood in the medium like that's not
what this movie was about okay like
that's why portraying somebody
what this movie about hey I'm with you
brother he even chose Bruce Lee cuz
really what if that scene is about is
cliff thinking that he's a badass and
then and later on you see that he is a
badass later on in the film so that
could have been like some giant six foot
five buff ass dude that he just randomly
beat up it didn't have to be it didn't
have to be three solution yeah nobody in
that era who directly one-to-one
translates a cliff booth thinks he's a
badass then beating up Bruce Lee like uh
like mr. t could be like mr. badass
though mr. t was laughed at mr. t was
was uh was seen as the joke like even I
think that's a different from the Rocky
started but that was the 80s my god pity
the fool is this whole thing like nobody
was like oh he was a wrestler right so
yeah I'm a wrestler first that turned
into yeah point being that's almost like
the thing right like it's like who's the
like who's the most badass of today it's
like Conor McGregor and all those guys
like it's like putting them in a movie
and having a clip booth kicked that
guy's ass and may portray Conor McGregor
as like a [ __ ] hot-headed piece of
[ __ ] because that's how he purchases all
the media but then his family's like oh
no he's actually a really super sweet
guy and he donates money to charity is
actually super cool but like we don't
give a [ __ ] about that we just want to
see the movie yeah yeah yeah that's I
think the I don't do all this [ __ ] where
it's like you have to portray somebody
the most perfect way in a movie like I'm
like let's [ __ ] around in the movie if
it's a biopic and you like disobey so
I'm a true story then yeah you have a
responsibility
but that ain't that that's not a bad pic
yeah yeah yeah I don't I don't I agree
to you could do whatever you want like
I'm even on the side of the camp where
you can't use legends like Jesus or MLK
or whatever and it make them an action
hero and like how Abraham Lincoln was
less a [ __ ] zombie hunter you could do
all those things but also you have to
understand that you are gonna piss
people off if you don't do a good job
but making them the best vampire hunter
he better be freed slaves to I'll be
pissed if he's not
[Music]